hey David can you delineate the factions
that exist on the Left right now so I'll
try to do this no I I don't think that
anyone will agree about the different
factions on the left that exists right
everybody would delineate it a little
bit differently but I'll give you my
take on it and you know with the caveat
that there is overlap between some of
these groups and there is some fluidity
between some of these groups so you have
what it what is called third way
politics which exists in both the
Democratic and the Republican Party but
it is in a sense it is it is sort of a
center-left centrism you could argue
that like Bill Clinton personified this
to some degree there is third way we
could call it third way centrism which
is a faction on the left it's a pretty
establishment faction of the left some
of you might call these establishment
shills although that's a pejorative term
so that's kind of one faction of the
left and I know that that one can be
characterized they know in a few
different ways there is what I call
modern progressivism and another way to
sort of call that would be true social
democracy okay so these are definitely
capitalists these are people who don't
want to destroy the system that we have
are by and large incrementalist s-- who
have seen the successes of social
democracy in other countries and they
want to move in that direction on the
basis that there are specific policy
ideas which if we elect the right people
the system that currently exists can be
tweaked and we can go in a direction
that would be often more like the
Scandinavian economic and social model
that's what I call modern progressivism
which takes into account things like
medicare-for-all or some other way of
getting to universal coverage we're
talking about in many cases housing
subsidies we're talking about maybe like
Bernie's plan to make tuition of at
state and local state schools of tuition
free
you're talking about paid maternity
leave you're talking about
democratization of the workplace to
different degrees still capitalism
modern progressivism is sort of like
true social democracy you then have
actual democratic socialism okay which
is a smaller subsection in the immediate
a lot of their goals are very similar to
those of the modern progressives in that
the next steps are very similar they may
want to totally socialize the means
ownership of the means of production but
for the most part the Democratic
Socialist will often agree that the next
step for their cause is the same one as
for Social Democrats which is we need to
make sure that we are supporting workers
rights and labor when it comes to health
care
modern progressives and Democratic
socialists for the most part want
something like Medicare for all
although they may disagree about the way
to implement it and this is actually
going to relate to our next audience
question which is about is the debate
between Social Democrats and Democratic
socialists one worth having right now
but I'll get to that later
so that's your Democratic socialists and
this is a term that's often misapplied
you will often have people who call
themselves Democratic socialists who
really aren't they're just modern
progressives they're Social Democrats
they don't want to socialize the means
of production they don't want the
government as involved as an actual
Democratic Democratic Socialist might
want then we get to and this is where it
starts to get a little tough we get to
what I believe are some of the fringe
groups and I want to be careful about
what term to use I'm not trying to be
pejorative although I think that these
groups often have a lot of bad ideas you
have a sort of you've got what sometimes
it's called the Leninist left you have
what sometimes are called tanki's and I
know that that's a pejorative term I'm
trying to find a non pejorative there is
sometimes overlap with a sort of more an
artistic movement within the left these
are relatively fringe and you will find
that they have overlap with some of
these other groups on foreign policy you
will sometimes see overlap between the
Leninist life
tanky types and Democratic socialists
although maybe for different reasons for
example you might have isolationists and
non interventionists who are actually
different politically that sometimes
we'll agree on what the policy should be
in a particular foreign policy situation
you will have Leninist left tanky types
and Social Democrats who might agree on
how should education and health care be
dealt with for example but there are
definitely some framing differences
where the Leninist left hankie side and
i if somebody has a better not I want a
non pejorative term for that group
please tell me what one would be if
there are times where when you get into
conversations of very basic things like
the concept of a nation state should
militaries exist where you will get to
like some pretty stark differences there
are there is also a strong actual
socialist communist component within the
Leninist left as the name probably
suggests you that is how I see the
divisions on the Left right now and I
for the most part think that it's great
to have these different factions you
know the Republican Party prior to Trump
did not suffer greatly because of the
three-way split between the Tea Party
types religious conservatives and
pro-business Republicans they had all
three they won thousands of seats at the
local level and up and it did not do
damage to them and I see no problem with
having all of these different groups
included in the context of the left when
it starts to become toxic and we've
talked about when it does I think it
does start to do damage to the movement
if you disagree with how I see the
modern left being divided up let me know
and please do let me know some other way
to refer to the Leninist left tanky
types I don't want it to be pejorative
it also can't be gushing right because I
do think that there are major problems
with that
that movement